E aí
Oi bom dia a todos meu nome é Rafael
como bem disse é o som dos fundadores da
simbiose social mas Startup que atua com
direcionamento de imposto para projetos
de impacto social é em menos de dois
anos de empresa a gente já atingiu o
potencial de mais de 100 milhões de
reais para projetos de impacto E
acabamos de ser indicado pela Fundação
schuab do fórum econômico Mundial para
ser um dos para o prêmio empreendedor
social do ano de 2018 e quando você bota
um empreendedor no palco Principalmente
quando as coisas começam a dar certo a
trajetória natural quase é colocar um
monte de slides contando da empresa e
começar a tentar fazer um Pitch
corporativo mostrar o modelo de negócio
como que as coisas estão dando certo
como que é fazer isso e eu fiz um
esforço muito grande para não ir para
essa linha aqui hoje e e contar um
pouquinho para vocês Como que foi a
minha escolha de empreender e depois de
empreender socialmente como e foi na
tomada de decisão assim que eu acho que
como muitos de vocês aqui eu tenho 24
anos eu sair de uma faculdade de
administração há pouco tempo e e eu
queria contar que essa história toda ela
começou quando eu era muito criança é o
primeiro contato que eu tive com o
empreendedorismo foi com sete anos de
idade e isso veio como quase que uma
válvula de escape é eu passava na minha
casa para uma série de problemas
familiares que uma criança às vezes não
consegui entender tudo aquilo que estava
acontecendo
e como válvula de escape para isso é eu
comecei a buscar coisas que me tirasse
daquele ambiente me desse prazer e
quisesse fazer feliz e por incrível que
pareça com sete anos de idade eu montei
minha primeira empresa
como que foi esse processo eu fui eu
tinha mudado de escola tava com uma nova
Turma com um monte de gente que eu não
conhecia Oi e eu ganhei da minha mãe uma
caixa de lápis como toda boa mãe né
filho mudou de escola dá uma caixa de
lápis para mim com mil lápis dentro
dessa caixa no caixa da Faber Castell
enorme e dentro disso O que que
aconteceu
eu peguei esses lápis não gostar de
prestar atenção na aula não queria ficar
vendo isso aí comecei a pegar tesoura
raspar os lápis lá e comecei a pintar
com um branquinho O olá fazer mal passar
trote mesmo na mesa né É E quando eu fui
ver o lápis ficou bonitinho para ficar
sequinha parece aquela de gesso eu
comecei a pintar Foi por esse negócio
que legal vou lá para os meus amigos em
vez de Down comecei a ver que eu podia
vender aqueles lápis meus amigos e
quando eu fui ver eu já tinha meus
primos raspando lápis o outro pintando
já tinha feito os amigos que eram quase
consultores de mim e eu tava vendendo
para mim escola para escola do lado para
os professores tive problema com o
consumidor né porque estragavam
apontador e as Crianças iam reclamar
comigo eu tenho que trocar o apontador
da Criança e esse processo foi quase que
um
engavetado por muitos outros que dos
sete anos 17 no processo da escola tinha
montado uns 12 negócio era conhecido
como mangueira da escola que agora vem
de coisa meio dia chocolate vem dia é
uma série de quando montava churrasco
levava tudo é isso sempre foi uma
válvula de escape para entender que
aquilo era uma paixão que eu tinha que
era uma forma de lidar com os meus
problemas a ser feliz eu gostava de
vender por vender é e esse processo
quase que naturalmente me colocou na
faculdade de administração onde eu
entrei essas habilidades eram
valorizadas lá dentro comecei a
trabalhar em empresa Júlia fazer isso
fazer aquilo e isso quase que como uma
regra vai sendo colocado um trilho para
você que você tem que entrar numa grande
empresa fazer um processo de estágio é e
trabalhar com isso é na época uma
empresa que valorizava suas habilidades
onde eu entrei era um deve Quase que o
extremo oposto do mundo dos projetos
sociais quem é e o meu processo dentro
também foi muito interessante eu entrei
o que seria a carreira do som os pais tô
achando uma maravilha um processo super
legal é aprendi muito lá dentro mas eu
comecei aprender qual que era a
diferença entre Inter e empreender
empreender quando a gente empreende você
pode tomar 99 não não mas se você tomar
um sim você consegue montar um negócio
entra empreender exatamente o contrário
você pode tomar 9095 possibilidade de
você ter ideia se você tomar um não o
negócio não anda e vai e prepara nesse
processo eu comecei a ter uma série de
frustrações e depois de dois anos eu
tinha entrado no processo de Trainee o
que era o sonho dos meus amigos o sonho
da turma e eu me encontrei não feliz e
eu não consigo entender porque que não
estava feliz por ela EA Carreira dos
sonhos era ela tudo mais faltava alguma
coisa para mim e eu acho que eu só
percebi isso quando eu descobri que tudo
que tava minha volta era muito mais
interessante do que eu trabalho eu fazia
a ver com essas coisas é do Inter na
condição de formatura da faculdade
quando estava me envolver com um monte
de coisa encontrei um grande amigo meu
na época que é uma cheques tá comigo até
hoje e e eu contei para ele dessas
mesmas angústias e vi que eu não estava
sozinho que ele tava passando as mesmas
angústias um processo de Trainee da
Unilever que também era o sonho da
família dele que era o sonho dos amigos
e que Poxa porque a gente não tá feliz
nesse meio tempo minha prima veio atrás
de mim a Helena é e ela pediu ajuda com
projeto social ela é a fundadora do
pronto sorriso que é um projeto como
doutores da Alegria de humanização
hospitalar Só que até então ela só tinha
conseguido trabalhar em hospitais
privados e o sonho dela era entrar no
hospital público ela fosse Olha a gente
consegue criar um
Oi e a lei de incentivo é permite com
que as empresas em vista o imposto delas
do projeto a gente vai eu preciso da sua
ajuda para vender esse projeto Uma
grande pessoa eu para vender eu gosto
vender eu sei e eu me juntei com a tia
estava começando a ficar ela vem comigo
um desenvolver esse projeto EA gente
começou a escrever aprovamos em seis
meses a gente tinha aprovado um projeto
na lei e vendido esse projeto para Itaú
que tinha investido 420 mil reais no
projeto e que fez com que ela pudesse
levar o projeto dela para Santa Casa de
Misericórdia e começou a atuar com uma
série de crianças que não tinha eu acho
que foi a primeira vez que eu tive o
contato com os alma habilidade minha
para algo que era além de mim era muito
legal que vem de lápis e quase que se
tornou impossível voltar para para o meu
trabalho e vem de guaraná é porque tava
muito distante esse processo então eu
comecei a entender que cara e eu posso
fazer algo além a entender que eu também
estava sendo que hora uma pessoa
extremamente privilegiada que eu tive
oportunidade de ter uma boa faculdade
que eu tive oportunidade de ter contato
com pessoas influentes que era uma
obrigação minha usado esse privilégio
para gerar algum retorno maior maior do
que eu e nesse processo também me
apaixonei por um conselho de leite
sentiu foi por agora deixa eu pegar esse
esse tema virou meu TCC comecei estudar
virei aqui dentro Uma coisa pessoal viu
o negócio da cabeça e começa a estudar
para caramba é meu TCC foi em cima disso
gente começou entender que não só
empresas podiam direcionar Mas qualquer
pessoa física podia pegar a parte do
Imposto delas e doar para uma causa
social no meio de uma crise política
isso é maravilhoso o dinheiro não
precisa ir pro governo pode direto para
a ponta e mudar a realidade do país aí
eu falei cara de uma onda de Cláudio
Fernandes Catarse surgindo motivos
precisamos criar uma plataforma onde
pessoas físicas com um clique pode
interessar na parte do Imposto delas
para projetos e social da época a gente
não entende absolutamente nada de
tecnologia trouxemos o Tadeu que era um
programador da BM que acima de tudo é
uma pessoa que estava alinhada com esses
propósitos que a gente conheceu na
trajetória e para ele ajudar a gente
desenvolver isso começamos a montar as
coisas e desenvolver a plataforma estava
super feliz mas aí quando eu me dei
conta eu tava trabalhando não deve sendo
presidente da comissão de formatura da
faculdade fazendo meu TCC e montando o
que os seria o início da simbiose essa
equação deu uma conta básica que o
resultado foi hipertensão com 22 anos
indo parar no hospital é sem conseguir
lidar que eu e a própria vida é E aí eu
comecei a falar assim calma não dá para
fazer tudo ao mesmo tempo minha mãe me
botou na parede e falou assim você é um
moleque você não sabe gerir o seu tempo
você não tá fazendo eu não quero que ter
um filho quem fato antes dos 30 então
você trate de escolher o que você vai
querer fazer da sua vida e meio que não
dava para parar de fazer o TCC Oi eu
tava no final para me informar também dá
uma palavra comissão de formatura foi
esse bom eu vou lhe dar e trabalhar com
o negócio aqui não tá mal existe ou eu
vou trabalhar com Ambev que é o sonho da
carreira eu fiz uma reunião familiar e
ver e para os meus pais e falei olha eu
vou me demitir não deve largar o
processo de treinamento e vou trabalhar
com o projeto social meu pai olhou para
mim falou assim moleque piu virou
comunista
largar tudo meu Deus do céu e aí eu
falei tchau tudo bem isso tentando Acre
outra crise familiar e eu lembro até
hoje 2016 dia três de agosto tava numa
sexta-feira
virei para o meu chefe como bom moleque
sem pensar muito ver e para deixar ele
não assada fácil Olha que coisa
maravilhosa vou criar uma empresa que
vai fazer isso que vai com clique em
direção à parte do Imposto dos projetos
para pessoas dos as pessoas para os
projetos é olha que maravilha E para
isso eu vou ter que ir em breve para
mudar o mundo
aí meu chefe olhou para mim falou se
você pirou
daí ele foi bem bem firme assim nas
falas dele né Ele virou para mim falou
assim amanhã muda o governo acaba a lei
de incentivo acaba as coisas negócio
vendo dá certo nunca é Você sabe quantos
candidatos são mtur vaga para entrar
aqui só mais de 30 mil candidatos se
você sair você não volta é você tem
calma e aí eu acho que ele ele fez uma
coisa que eu acho que foi uma das mais
difíceis para mim que ele falou se eu
vou fingir que eu não ouvi o que você
falou e eu vou sair daqui você fala com
seus pais acho que eles devem ter um
pouquinho mais de consciência e a gente
fala na próxima semana novamente para
ver o que que como que a gente vai o
qual vai ser sua escolha foi uma das
piores semanas da minha vida era aquela
sensação de estômago embrulhado sonhava
com isso quase todas as noites um dia eu
tinha tomado certeza absoluta vou largar
isso tudo no dia seguinte eu já não
tenho certeza de nada no outro Já te
aceitei e na carreira da vida e nessa
semana vários projetos entraram legais
para caramba no processo e eu chegou no
dia dez na semana seguinte 96 da manhã
meia hora antes da reunião e eu não
fazia a menor ideia do que eu ia fazer
eu resolvi um conselho a minha mãe que
ela falou assim siga seu coração quer
saber o que significava né mas eu falei
vou entrar na reunião e fazer o que seja
o que Deus quiser entrei na reunião
falei olha isso mesmo eu vou querer
montar um negócio vai dar certo a gente
vai mudar o mundo você vai ver E aí ele
virou para mim falou assim não sem
problemas Boa sorte vai lá nem precisa
voltar segunda-feira foi falta dois tá
bom beleza vamos lá como bom
empreendedor sair pulei fora da neve e
falei vamos montar um negócio agora para
o somos que trabalhar vou ter tempo as
coisas vão andar tudo mais e como
contranota dinheiro tinha aos pais dos
amigos dos fios que estavam vendo
falando que a que bonitinho o Rafael vai
para a ideia que legal deixa eu ajudar
é de uma amiga minha que era tia Bete
ela era uma grande advogada tributarista
e ela falou assim eu posso dar uma ajuda
para vocês no dia seguinte o que
permitirá sábado eu fui lá fazer uma
reunião com ela sair para jantar e
comecei a contar sua história para ela
olha a gente vai voar Contigo sou no
posto da pessoa física para o projeto e
aí ela olhou para mim e falou assim
Então Rafael Muito legal essa ideia mas
o que você tá querendo fazer é crime e
eu eu fiquei pálido não consegui
terminar de jantar e a única coisa que
passava na minha cabeça era eu vou
voltar segunda-feira não deve falar
assim e aí é vocês acreditaram que a
vida mentira olha quantos candidatos são
por vaga para entrar aqui eu comecei a
foi meu ferrou né sair do jantar é 11
meio da noite liguei para o Matias
liguei para o Tadeu matinal no jogo do
Corinthians para se você venha para
minha casa agora os dois e chegaram em
casa é 11 tanto da noite eu tô aqui na
face olhando eu fui o único que me
demitir aqueles negócio eu não vou virar
para o meu pai para o meu padrasto da
minha mãe da minha família toda e dizer
que eu esqueci de perguntar para o
advogado se podia fazer e que a empresa
tinha durado menos de 24 horas da minha
demissão eu já tinha quebrado o modelo
de negócio porque não é com muito básico
para não ter dá certo e a gente se
trancou no quarto naquele dia e e
começamos a redesenhar todo o modelo a
gente nós passamos a madrugada inteira
desenhando fala assim calma talvez não
seja a pessoa física Talvez seja
empresas talvez não seja projeto assim
talvez a gente consiga ir atrás dos
dados e por isso não é nada transparente
isso tem um monte de problema é isso e o
que era para ser uma das noites que eu
ia dormir mais desesperado minha vida
sem hora que nenhum foi uma das noites
mais tranquilas para mim onde ele
comecei a ter a certeza de que não era o
produto em si mas era com pessoas certas
com um propósito comum e com uma demanda
efetivamente existente a gente já
consegui se adaptaria e criar uma coisa
nova e foi assim o processo da primeira
semana da empresa onde tinha um
funcionário
interno que passou a C2 que passou a ser
15 que até o fim do ano estão chegando e
25 agora mas que nesse processo a gente
conseguiu entender a problema de a Jesus
entrar com lei de Transparência contra
todos os Ministérios e secretarias cria
robôs que baixaram todos os dados
públicos mapearam mais de 70 bilhões de
reais
encontrar mais de 200 mil projetos e
criar um sistema que hoje é o sistema
que é o da simbiose mas que não sei se
vai ser amanhã se não sei se vai ser
depois e que pouco importa como que é o
produto mas consegui encontrar uma forma
de apoiar Os projetos que a gente
acreditava e isso tudo quando a gente
faz com uma
certeza muito grande e com um propósito
Claro quase que uma pulguinha que vai
contagiando as pessoas e a gente teve
uma série de pessoas que a gente são
quase anjos para gente que voaram
abrindo portas e que fizeram com menos
de um ano e meio de empresa a gente vai
completar um ano e meio agora no próximo
mês
fazer com que a gente fizesse parte do
primeiro centro de inovação do Facebook
no mundo fizesse que a gente integrasse
a plataforma com inteligência artificial
da Intel na nos Estados Unidos
e com que a gente tem que criar um
sistema que tem que empresas hoje como
Volkswagen João Solutions from Croton
Uber Via Varejo Raia Drogasil Facebook
que direção todo o imposto deles projeto
pelo nosso sistema com a essência Clara
hoje eu não tenho 24 anos cara e tem
muitos desafios que a gente passa nesse
processo que demanda ter um Norte muito
Claro não é fácil não é fácil e cada dia
só muda o desespero Mas tem que tomar
uma gestão emocional que saber que não é
fácil saber que não você não sabe fazer
tudo é fundamental
para que você possa fazer porque você
vai naturalmente trazer pessoas para
perto que vão saber fazer isso e que tem
sido um sucesso muito grande então o que
eu queria contar para vocês hoje não era
tanto a parte do Pit da empresa mas
contar um pouco de algumas falhas desse
processo é de que a gente passou aí de
que eu não me arrependo em nada de ter
largado o meu trabalho estamos agora no
fim desse ano é começando um
relacionamento para próprio breve para
ela usar Nossa plataforma O que é uma
sensação até que estranha dentro desse
processo todo mas que vai validando
porque no fim das contas eu acho que
todo mundo tem um objetivo comum que é
ser feliz
e isso naturalmente a gente vai
entendendo se a gente tá indo para o
caminho certo se a gente está sendo
feliz agora eu acho que tem Óbvio muitas
empresas e pessoas que têm o perfil
Empresarial mas tem muita gente tem o
perfil de empreender e que as vezes
acaba não tendo a coragem de dar esse
passo
e esse processo ele é fundamental Não é
uma linha certa é pode ter altos e
baixos mas se você tem um Norte certo se
você sabe para onde ir Isso tem uns e
como muito obrigado a todos pela atenção
eu sou Rafael e é isso aí ó
E aí